♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
HAPPY JUNE.
SO YESTERDAY CNN HELD TOWN
HALL WITH A TRIO OF
CANDIDATES.
ALL THREE OF THEM ARE THE
DEMOCRATIC MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS.
NONE IS IN DANGER OF BECOMING
PRESIDENT ANYTIME SOON.
AND WHY DO WE PAY ATTENTION TO
WHAT THEY SAY?
BECAUSE AS THEY STAMMER AND
SWEAT AND PANDER FOR
PROFUSELY, THEY GIVE US A GOOD
IDEA OF WHAT THE DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY VOTERS BELIEVE AND
WHAT THEY CARE ABOUT.
WHAT THEY CARE ABOUT MOST AND
WHAT THEY CAN'T STOP TALKING
ABOUT EVER IS RACE.
THEY ARE OBSESSED IN A DEEPLY
UNHEALTHY WAY.
RACIAL OBSESSIONS ARE ALWAYS
DEEPLY UNHEALTHY.
WATCH SETH MOLTON TALK ABOUT
HOW THEY DIDN'T ELECT STACEY
ABRAMS GOVERNOR NOT BECAUSE
SHE WOULDN'T A GOOD GOVERNOR
BUT THEY ARE BIGOTS.
>> IF SHE WASN'T PERSON OF
COLOR SHE WOULD BE GOVERNOR.
>> SO HE WENT TO HARVARD
UNLIKE YOU SO HE MUST BE A
VERIFIED GENIUS AND GOOD
PERSON, TOO.
BUT SOMEHOW MOLITOR DIDN'T
BOTHER TO MUSTER A SINGLE
PIECE OF EVIDENCE TO SHOW ANY
OF HIS CLAIMS WERE TRUE.
BECAUSE ACTUALLY THEY'RE NOT
TRUE IT'S NOT 1953 ANYMORE.
THEY CAN'T LET YOU KNOW THAT.
FOR SETH MOULTON PURPOSES OF
CONTROL IT HAS TO BE JIM CROW
ALABAMA AT ALL TIMES NOW AND
FOREVER.
BURNING CROSSES IN THE SOUND
OF NIGHT RIDERS IN THE
DISTANCE.
THAT WILL KEEP YOU TERRIFIED
AND EASIER TO MANIPULATE.
THAT IS THE WHOLE POINT.
EISENHOWER SENT THE 101st
AIRBORNE TO BRING THE SOUTH TO
HEAL.
BUT MODERN DEMOCRATIC PARTY
HAS BIG BUSINESS TO MAKE THEM
OBEY.
WATCH THIS.
>> WE HAVE NETFLIX,NY, WARNER
MEDIA WHICH OWNS CNN AND THEY
HAVE WARNED THEY MAY FAULT
BUSINESS HERE IF THE LAW GOES
INTO EFFECT.
I WONDER DO YOU SUPPORT THAT
ECONOMIC BOYCOTT?
>> IF THE LAW GOES INTO EFFECT
I DO.
CNN MAY HAVE TO MOVE.
A LOT OF YOUNG WOMEN WHO WORK
AT CNN.
>> Tucker: DO I SUPPORT
PUTTING BIG COMPANIES IN
CHARGE OF AMERICA SOCIAL
POLICY, HE WAS ASKED?
OF COURSE I SUPPORT THAT.
SCREW THE VOTERS.
THEY ARE IRRELEVANT.
THE BILLIONAIRE DONORS WILL
BRING BACK THE ABORTION FAIRY.
NOTICE THE APPLAUSE FROM THE
AUDIENCE.
THEY LOVE THAT.
THE DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY
SUPPORTS LOVE THAT A
BILLIONAIRE WILL RIDE TO THE
RESCUE AND MAKE EVERYTHING
OKAY.
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY DON'T LIKE?
THEY DON'T LIKE THE REALITY.
THAT INFURIATES THEM.
BIOLOGY IS REAL.
RUSSIA DID NOT BEAT HILLARY.
GLOBAL WARMING ISN'T ACTUALLY
KILLING MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
NOW.
ALL TRUE STATEMENTS AND IT
DRIVES THEM BONKERS BECAUSE
IT'S TRUE.
WATCH THE RESPONSE FROM JOHN
HICKENLOOPER WHO IS ALSO
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT TO
REMIND THEM THAT SOCIALISM
DOESN'T REALLY WORK.
>> IF WE WANT TO BEAT DONALD
TRUMP AND ACHIEVE BIG
PROGRESSIVE GOALS, SOCIALISM
IS NOT THE ANSWER.
I WAS RE-ELECTED --
[BOOING]
IF WE ARE NOT CAREFUL, WE WILL
HELP RE-ELECT THE WORST
PRESIDENT IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
>> Tucker: THAT IS THE POINT
WHERE HICKENLOOPER SHOULD HAVE
PASSED AND CALLED OUT THE
AUDIENCE AND ASK THEM TO NAME
A SINGLE PLACE OUTSIDE OF
SWEDEN IN THE 1970s WHERE
SOCIALISM ACTUALLY WORKED.
ANYONE?
BUT OF COURSE HE DIDN'T DO
THAT.
HE WAS AFRAID.
GOD KNOWS WHAT THE MOB WOULD
HAVE DONE IF HE TRIED.
WATCH WHAT HAPPENED TO JOHN
DELANY, THE BRAVEST MAYBE OF
ANYONE IN RACE WHEN HE
SUGGESTED THE THAT MEDICARE
FOR ALL MIGHT NOT BE A GREAT
IDEA.
>> MEDICARE FOR ALL MAY SOUND
GOOD BUT IT'S ACTUALLY NOT
GOOD POLICY, NOR IS IT GOOD
POLITICS.
I'M TELLING YOU.
100 --
[BOOING]
>> Tucker: HE IS DYING OUT
THERE.
BOO!
STOP HIM BEFORE HE HURTS OUR
DREAMS!
IF HE WANT IT TO BE TRUE, IT
MUST BE TRUE SCREENED THE
4-YEAR-OLD.
I'M THE CENTER OF THE
UNIVERSE.
CATER TO ME.
TELL ME I'M WONDERFUL.
IF YOU STRIP IT AWAY THAT IS
THE MESSAGE OF THE DEMOCRATIC
VOTERS.
200-PROOF NARCISSISM.
GIVE US MORE!
[LAUGHTER]
THE NARCISSIST IN CHIEF WAS
OFFENDED.
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ WENT
ON TWITTER AND DEMANDED THAT
HE GET OUT OF THE RACE.
THAT DOESN'T IN THE END BODE
WELL FOR DEMOCRATS.